hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game from yesterday's round
five of the us chess championship it's
fabiana carwana versus daniel naraditsky
it's around five uh like we already
mentioned and um well fabi's doing okay
as he usually does uh no losses so far
and narudinski playing very very
aggressive chess as he usually does uh
currently with one win the one that
we've shown and three losses so this is
a a really brilliant game uh let's check
it out uh fabi with the white pieces
opens with e4
we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 fabi goes for the royal
opus and a6 morphe's defense is on the
board we have bishop to a4 and now d6
going for the modern steins defense so
the dark square bishop will not be
developed uh not like that but obviously
aggressively like this but instead we're
gonna i play g6 in fiance to our dark
square bishop so castles by fabi bishop
to d7 and now c3 making room for the
bishop if needed uh we have knight to f6
and now rook to e1 defending our e for
pawn we have g6 uh black prepares the
fiance of the bishop then castle and
fabi strikes in the center with d4 with
bishop to g7 and now knight b to d2 both
players just continuing with the usual
stuff and fabi knows this position
incredibly well as he already had a game
in this exact same position however he
had the black pieces it was in the 2018
chess olympiad in batumi against the
tutsiani and that game ended in a draw
where fabi just continued with castles
but here narudisky plays e counter
sunday four goes for this early trade in
the center and now it is already as of
move nine that we have a completely new
game
so c captures on v4 fabi uh of course
improves his center and now black
castles we have h3 taking away the g4
square from black's pieces and now
knight to knights to b4 and here we can
already see uh some of black's plans of
course so we want to trade off the the
light square bishop here but also we
want to play knight to d3 to go after
the rook and the bishop here because our
dark square bishop is a monster often
referred to as the dragon here because
it's uh just controls so much and if we
could eliminate the white star square
bishop then our own dark square bishop
will be unopposed for the rest of the
game hopefully so here bishop captures
and these seven queen captures and now
queen b3 attacking the knight and
stopping knights to d3 uh with a5 the
knight is now nicely defended and a3 we
chase it away knights to c6 and now
knight to f1 the usual stuff the knight
cannot come to g3 to e3 to h2 all
depends on what black plays
and now a4
this is now
pretty much standard stuff we want to
grab as much space as possible
we have queen to d3 and now we've freed
up the a5 square for our knight and also
created a very nice outpost on b3 for
this knight so let's start with that
knight to a5 uh and fabi finally gets to
develop his um dark square bishop with
bishop to g5 knight to b3 putting
pressure on the rook and rook a to d1 so
it's a great square for the knight uh
but for the moment uh it doesn't have
all that many targets and now uh uh
naruto just plays h6 he says all right
what are you going to do with the bishop
uh if you play knight bishop the c1 or
d2 i can always trade it and this will
be very good for me even though this is
a
beautifully active knight uh we want to
trade our knight for bishop uh because
then our bishop will be just a monster
here here fabi has a weak uh backwards
b2 pawn and it could be an issue if an
end game occurs where these pawn starts
starts marching forward
so here uh fabi could go back for
example bishop to e3 is possible but it
looks like a passive square for the
bishop we're already attacking the four
pawn the the rook is uh
the rook and queen are defending but uh
you know it doesn't look like a very
natural square for this bishop uh so
instead of fabi decides to trade this
bishop uh bishop captures an f6 bishop
captures and now knight 1 to d2 we want
to get rid of this powerful knight on b3
so naruto just brings it back knight to
a5 and now the knight can come to c6 but
also you can play b5 and then create
another outpost for this knight on c4
fabi plays knight to b1 uh he could go
for e5 right away but he he's waiting
with that move he plays knight b1 he
wants to bring it to the natural c3
square and now b5 uh we want to play
knight to c for now because the knight
moved from d2 and you are no longer
controlling the c4 square so queen to c2
and now bishop back to g7 uh now fabi is
ready to push e5 the queen moved away
from the d file and we want to use uh
that the the idea that the black queen
is still uh occupying the d7 square so
bishop back to g7 knight to c3 and now
c6 so improving our position a little
bit uh and controlling this knight on c3
fabi finally executes e5 and now rook f2
e8 we have knight to e4
and even though it seems like the e5
pawn is not hanging because black is
attacking it three times that's not
really true because if you capture the
pawn let's say we capture we open up a
discovery here and after the queen moves
we simply play queen c3 and now yes uh
it seems like black can again capture
the pawn but if you go after this it
already sounds very very suspicious as
you don't want to give up your dark
square bishop even for the price of a
pawn most of the times but here it just
loses by force knight captures rook
captures and now knight d6 just wins the
game your queen is attacked your rook is
attacked twice so you have to trade here
with check captures captures and now
uh the the the queen and knight combo is
simply too strong here your queen is
attacked you have to move it let's say
knight e4 goes after f6 and this with
the queen controlling this diagonal in
the knight having uh unrestricted access
to the f6 square this is a game over
most of the times for example queen d8
we can just play knight f6 czech king
here and now anything is winning for
white even the barbaric uh rook to e8
check that's sufficient for white to win
so it seems like uh the pawn can be
captured but not really so here another
ski just continues improving knight to
c4 now puts pressure on the b2 pawn uh
and uh e captures and d6 finally we
capture this knight captures on d6 and
now knight the e5 attacking the queen
here so queen to f5 of course we do not
want to give up our strong bishop here
and now you can't go after the knight
yes it's undefended but your queen is
hanging on c2 i know some of you were
thinking about grabbing this knight
so here we have g4 chasing back the
queen queen to e6 boldly stepping in
front of the rook but uh
for the moment there's no way to take
advantage of this if you go for example
knight captures queen captures uh you
could go knight captures on c6 and this
wins you upon temporarily but it doesn't
look like it's a very good idea like
rook the c8 is coming then we're gonna
play rook to d8 and we're gonna win back
this pawn at some point but it seems
like uh
uh well a solid thing for example if
magnus if fabi had this position against
magnus he would probably go for this and
uh you know just try and play it play it
on uh but here of course here there's uh
the difference of the rating so fabi has
to has to win this game not only to
improve his chances of uh winning the
usgs championship uh but also not to
lose too much rating because he is much
much higher rated than everyone else
here so knight back to c3 and now comes
rook a to c8 you will no longer uh be
capturing the c6 pawn rook to e2 fabi
wants to double up here on the e file
and now comes queen to b3 offering a
queen trade and uh uh fabi uh agrees to
this trade we have queen captures eight
characters and now king to g2 starting
to improve the position of the king
maybe f4 was worth considering here uh
because after king to g2 naruto just
plays c5 and it of course makes very
good sense uh since you want to remove
the defender of the knight on e5 on the
other hand d captures on c5 also attacks
the knight here so this has to be
calculated uh very very precisely so the
captures on c5 is played by fabi and now
knight to c4 now okay fabi is upon
temporarily but we have a lot of
pressure on this b2 pawn our bishop is a
monster here the knight here is attacked
three times so you have to you have to
do something fabi decides to capture on
c4 you could also play knight to d3 and
then go for something like bishop
captures on c3 here we will give up our
very strong bishop because it creates
just a beautiful pass pawn here but uh
of course
you're not going to play this you're
going to play rook captures on e8 check
rook captures and only now captures b
captures on c3 and now you have this
position where you can win back your
pawn at any time but you have just a
beautiful past pawn here on on b3 so
that's one option uh however after
knight to c4 fabi decided to go for
knight captures on c4 and now we have
rook capture sunny to knight captures on
e2 and now b captures on c4
and now rook to c1 uh so we have to
prevent this uh
uh well we we have to prevent uh like
bishop captures on b2 we could go and
try to prevent this with sound like
knight to c3 but still we can always
give up this bishop and be left with a
with an incredibly strong pass pawn here
for example rook captures on c5 yes
white also has a pass pawn but black's
past pawn is already on b3 and this is
uh
very ugly to look at so fabi tries to
rook the c1 and now of course bishop
captures on b2 we have rook captures on
c4 bishop captures on a3 and now c6
fobby advances is pawn to a light square
and now the material uh
balance has been restored and we have to
figure out how to continue playing this
we have b2 and now the question is is
the bishop here stronger than the knight
or is the knight stronger so let's see
after a few moves what happens of course
we have to prevent queening b1 queen
just wins the game so knight to c3
stopping this and now bishop back to f8
now the bishop will be put on g7 to
harass the knight of course the knight
will be forced to come to b1 and remain
there for a very long time so knight to
b1 and now bishop to g7 so now if you
evaluate this position uh you can
pretty much uh agree that the bishop is
at least a little bit stronger than this
knight because the bishop can freely
roam anywhere it wants the b coupon
isn't even under any pressure so you
could even move it temporarily
but the knight can't really go anywhere
it can come to a3 and then go back to b1
that's pretty much uh all that this
knight can do okay you can go to d2 but
uh
after that so king f3 we have to start
improving the position of our king in
the end game and of course black does
this as well king f8 and now not king e4
right away fabi first plays this h4 move
he wants to play h5
and narudinski just continues improving
the position of his king with h5 king to
d6 and now h captures on g6 fabi has to
create some weaknesses on the king's
side because he knows that he will not
be able to defend this pawn forever so
we have pawn captures on g6 and now rook
to b4
this pawn is lost so you have to
uh
you have to decide on how to do it and
here naruditsuki grabs it with the rook
if you capture it with the king
you have to be very very sure that rook
the c4 check doesn't uh
allow white to easily draw the game but
here it doesn't so king captures can
also be played however he captures with
the rook
and now rook to b7 going after the
bishop and now the real question is does
rook c1 win the game on the spot or is
this just a draw we're gonna show this
very briefly because it's uh you know we
have to consider it i mean if it does
there's no point in playing anything
else uh the point is after rook captures
on g7 rook captures on c1 now we're
ready to move our rook and promote our
pawn so rook to b7 and now uh okay now
you can't really move the rook because
rook capture spawn will happen but the
problem is after something like h5
captures and captures the white king
cannot go anywhere else it has to remain
on the f file because if you go anywhere
uh okay not maybe not on the second rank
the the second rank um
uh you can't deliver a check but
anywhere else uh if you allow the black
rook to deliver a check uh then that
this pawn will be promoted uh very
easily so here we would see something
like rugby six check king e5 rook the b5
check uh but we don't really care king
b4 you can't really capture the pawn
because we just move our rook and
promote this spawn so rook to b8 and
here the problem is after some like h4
we're going to play king to g2
even h3 is possible white can just play
king h2 and this is perfectly fine
there's no way to
uh gain any advantage here with black so
we're going to play something like king
to c3 but not rook to c8 to check and
we're just going to happily continue
checking the black king and there's no
way for black to make progress here so
although it seems like a fine idea it's
uh insufficient so here we have bishop
to e5 if it doesn't work by force no
point in calculating it we're just going
to keep our stronger piece uh and now
we're going to improve the position of
our own king we have knight to d2 and
now rook to c2 putting pressure on the
knight king the e3 defending uh and now
uh it's not a problem because uh the the
the pawn here is guarded but uh if and
the b1 square is um not guarded by black
so you don't have to worry about
something like rook captures knight so
here uh there are a couple of moves you
can play black is completely winning
here but feel free to pause the video
and try to find uh the cleanest way to
win this with black while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding any of the
nice ideas like rook to c1 is a very
nice idea pushing h5 is a nice idea king
to c5 is a very nice idea so those are
all interesting moves but king to c6 is
just
incredibly forcing so congratulations to
everyone who found this you are a true
spotter of excellent moves in very
complicated end games
uh and of course for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show that's the
move king to c6 and now the problem is
you don't really have any good squares
for this rook to remain on the b file if
rook to be for bishop c3 and that's game
uh so you have to play rook to b3 it's
ugly but it has to be played and now of
course rook the c3 check now we get rid
of the rooks of the board and then it's
a bishop against knight with games with
game on both sides of the board and we
are up upon so of course that's more
than we could ask for real captures
bishop captures of course with the
threat of just eliminating the defender
of the b1 square so knight b1 pretty
much forced and now bishop to b4
guarding all the squares that this
knight can do to jump anywhere and
that's pretty much it fabi plays f4
trying to create a pass pawn but it's
not a problem king to d5 king to d3
stopping the black king from advancing
but now h5 the white king is now very
far away from this h pawn and we can't
really uh capture this if we play
captures captures king e3 h4 king f3
just king c4 and you don't really care
king g4 king d3 and now after you
capture the pawn king c2 and that's it
you don't have to worry about this pawn
because the bishop covers the queening
square
and there are no moves here for white so
instead after h5 fabi played f5 he wants
to create either this spawn or cap or
cactus and then create this passport
we have h captures and g for now f
captures on g6 and now you have to be
very very careful here you don't want to
blunder a completely winning game so we
are outside the square of the pawn so
i'll move like king the e6 has to be
played or even bishop to f8 to stop the
pawn from reaching g7 but since our
bishop is on uh such a lovely square it
makes no sense to you know
move the bishop so king e6 was played
king to e4 now comes g3 we have king to
f3 going after the pawn but now bishop
to d6 guarding the g3 pawn and he was in
this position on 57 that fabiana corona
resigned the game and another brilliant
victory for daniel narudicki in round
five of the usgs championship 2021. so
interestingly uh daniel still has no
draw so two wins three losses he is
definitely the
uh he definitely came here to fight and
you know it doesn't matter if he wins or
loses he he always puts up uh puts up a
show and that's uh well that's what we
really want so here you resign as
there's no way for you to do anything
we're gonna win this pawn and then it's
just completely hopeless for example
knight to c3 king f6 king e3 doesn't
really matter king captures on g6 king
f3 king h5 and now you're gonna escort
this pawn down the board doesn't really
matter king g2 king g4 king f1 king f3
king the g1 we're gonna push g2 that's
it there's nothing left to be done here
knight to d1 and now i know you guys
really want to push this pawn and
promote it to a queen but this would be
stalemate so be careful uh in your own
games not to do something like this so
now we ignore this we play bishop c5
check king h2 and now g1 queen with
check king king h3 now let's say queen
g3 checkmate or even queen h1 it's also
very nice checkmate uh so yeah after
bishop to d6 fabi resigned and a
wonderful victory for daniel narudicki
and this is a
great stuff of course for for daniel but
a really tough blow for fabi uh not only
to his chances of winning the usgs
championship as he is the number one
seed in this tournament but also to his
classical rating
which took a really severe blow he's now
down to 27 91 or something like that
so it will uh take uh take a lot of
effort to get back uh to 2800 of course
it's uh uh
unrealistic that it could happen in this
tournament unless he wins like the next
five games uh but maybe when he plays a
classical tournament where players are
you know uh
closer to his own rating
uh so yeah
that's uh the game hope you guys enjoyed
it something that
happens uh from time to time uh when
such a such a high rated player plays
against a lower rated player then he has
to resort to
you know lines that avoid the draws and
he has to try try and win the game
sometimes this also means giving your
opponent opportunities and naraditsuki
exploited those opportunities incredibly
well
uh so once again hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank uh be malta
pedro cool la miranda iron sp michael
kennedy and tom carr for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
all for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the usgs
championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day